nous avons choisi ce thème car il
concerne un grand nombre d'adolescents
dans un monde où la connectivité est
présente des jeunes pour parler avec des
jeunes du cyber harcèlement dans le
cadre de leur projet d'initiative et de
communication ces quatre étudiants en 2e
année de BTS agricole ont organisé une
conférence à la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet tabou dépression et suicide
une réalité présentée face à 155
auditeurs majoritairement lycéen ce
jeudi 9 novembre on a décidé parce que
enfin il y a beaucoup d'élèves
maintenant qui se font harcelés c'est
enfin souvent le cas et on s'est dit que
l'exposé peut-être ça aiderait des
personnes à en parler et en plus on a
fait ça le 9 novembre où c'est le jour
contre le l'harcèlement parce que des
fois on a honte on se dit on abuse un
peu ça se trouve c'est pas de
l'harcèlement ou justement on se moque
encore plus parce que on dit qu'on se
fceler alors que d'autres gens ils
pensent que non définir ce type de
violence ou savoir comment mieux s'en
protéger pour animer cette rencontre ses
étudiants ont convié la capitaine Katia
landet de la Police Nationale de
Rambouillet des discussions interactif
pour mieux prendre conscience des
répercussions psychologiques la majorité
des cas de cyberhcèlement trouve leur
origine au sein des établissements
scolair c'est d'ailleurs ce que je leur
explique je leur dis que le harcèlement
a été inventé avec l'école mais que si
il prend autant d'ampleur de nos jours
et s'il est aussi grave en conséquence
puisque malheureusement les cas de
suicide sont très nombreux c'est parce
qu'il il se nourrit des des réseaux
sociaux et de l'usage qui peut être fait
des téléphones j'ai appris la différence
entre cyber harcèlement harcèlement et
tout ça j'ai appris les conséquences
qu' peut y avoir et ça non franchement
j'ai trouvé ça vraiment intéressant et
c'est quelque chose qui est quand même
assez handicapant et qui bloque et qui
ferme pas mal de portes donc je pense
que oui actuellement c'est quelque chose
qui faut encourager les jeunes à aller
voir et discuter pas forcément force de
l'ordre en premièrement mais dà discuter
auprès de sa famille auprès de ses amis
le phénomène du cyberhcèlement prend de
plus en plus d'ampleur selon un récent
sondage une famille sur 4 aurait déjà
été confronté à ce fléo